What does it mean to evaluate
opportunity cost and
how can you use it to make better
decisions for your business?
As an entrepreneur,
you're going to face a ton of decisions,
and you'll have to adapt to
new situations as they unfold.
What if new opportunities come up.
What if things take
longer than expected or
maybe things actually go
quicker than you thought.
When this happens, you'll need to
change gears and adjust your direction.
But how do you know which way to go?
One way to figure this out is to
evaluate the opportunity cost of your
decisions.
So what's opportunity cost?
Opportunity cost is the loss of
potential gain from other alternatives
when one alternative is chosen.
In other words, every decision you make
has a potential gain associated with it.
And any time you choose one option,
you're missing out on the potential
gains of a different option.
It's up to you to compare
each decision and
determine which one has
the most potential gain.
This will minimize the opportunity
cost of the direction you take.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Here's a few questions you can ask
yourself to help evaluate your
opportunity cost.
Is there something I
could be doing right now
that would be a better use of my time?
Is there any way I could be managing
my resources better and how could I put
myself on my team in a position to
make the best use of their skills?
Any time that you're not doing these
things as effectively as you could be
your actions have some opportunity
cost associated with them.
There are more specific values you
can start to place on these numbers.
But getting this basic mindset
is a great place to start.
Moving forward, try to think,
what else could I be doing right now?
Is there a way my time, money, or
resources could be better spent?
>From there, you can start weighing
the opportunity cost of each
decision you make.